yeah so anyways Croatia yeah yeah what's
the deal with that guy can you give us
some money so you know when I was doing
the podcast before this one
I just would know and oh yeah when you
were just spreading your legs for that
other party yeah yeah you know on my
Tour on the ground you know you know
that was hurtful for me what just
watching on all these podcasts I'm like
you're hurting her
I want to ask him that hey hey I want to
ask him that it gave us lots of good
content here the self-deprecation I did
it for you okay fair now this one's the
funniest but somehow I ended up winning
like 110 Grand off now and then I was
like just give it to some kid in Croatia
because they're going to Croatia what do
you mean won it off Milk uh we played
poker so we did the podcast oh you did
the steak thing no just we played heads
up poker oh and then uh yeah 110 Grand
and I just totally give it to someone in
Croatia because that's where they're
going wow and that happened today yeah
like 10 minutes ago they just gave it to
somebody incredible no so they're going
there and they're gonna give the 110 I
won away just by picking someone I don't
know I told him to do it and when Beast
says do it I mean it's that or they pay
me so at least if they give it to
someone in Croatia content I have to say
every time I see you play poker I'm
jealous because I love playing poker do
you really yes but I don't have anyone
to play with wait really yeah you want
to play after this I don't have your
money bro we can play 10 G's if you want
I heard
I I'll just leave
oh we can play with like something small
then yeah like 100k 100K yeah you guys
didn't mean it like I just love when he
goes like I think people vastly
underestimate how you how much YouTube
would make like yeah
yeah yeah YouTubers definitely make a
lot of people just because we I just
played with no for 100 so I was just
throwing a smaller number yeah no it's
fine that's fine I think Ludwig invited
me to the one that you guys did in Vegas
and he said the same thing he was like
yeah buy-in is like 20 or 50 no that was
50 yeah 50k yeah I have one yeah no half
a million dollars did you really yeah
how long you've been playing poker not
long at all like a year do you just love
the game I just like putting people in
uncomfortable positions like even if I
have [ __ ] cards I'll just shove all in
and I just know that like like there are
just certain people who just don't like
that and so then they fold a bunch and I
just slowly take money yeah and um yeah
so I usually just Target those players
and just like put a lot of pressure at
them so do you mainly play cash games or
do you like playing tournament games as
well I haven't played in probably like
six months outside of what I did about
today okay
um but yeah I mean it's got to be like a
big game where it's just not really that
much fun
that's just so funny dude I just picture
him at like a World Series of Poker
Tournament all these dudes play all year
long he just sits down firsthand he's
like oh all in like dude I did that on
uh come on man I was on this TV show
poker after dark yeah yeah I sat at the
table I was a little late and then it
was like Ted Cruz and like a bunch of
other people I've never met before but
like just names you would recognize Ted
Cruz yeah I didn't even know he was
going to be there please tell me he
played poker with Ted Cruz well so I sat
down I was late and then with all these
like famous people but he was bad at
poker right I don't know well so
literally firsthand I was just as a joke
I I just didn't even look at my hand I
was like all in and then like the dude
to my left got like pocket aces and he's
like cool and I literally was I sat down
and I got up like 30 seconds later and
so like this Big Show and I was like the
headliner they're like Mr Beast is here
and then I was there for like 30 seconds
oh no yeah what up everybody
let's do it call is he headed back to
the airport
time they're so mad at me they're like
you want to just chill at the table it's
like no that's kind of boring
wow I didn't do it on purpose though I
just thought it'd be funny yeah they're
like all in just like what was it like
50 G's or 100 just like throw it in and
then yeah that's so good it's great for
the dude that was next to you yeah the
producers were like no
they almost
it's like this setup but like 10 times
more cameras and if he's the producer
he's like
yeah he's planning for like a three hour
run of show where he's like oh this
would be great we'll have Beasts here
and then yeah
yeah exactly our story through and the
Beats all in wait what was it
just yanking his head
hi sir he almost ran in there I was like
no stop yeah yeah I just snap call
no no don't call you yeah the producer
just runs across the room just kill
just throws his whole body at his neck
oh the guy's like I caught
oh his C3 is broken no no he's like he
he calls and then like the deal is like
what's that over there and swaps his
cards out and it goes from like Aces to
seven too yeah and he's like I swear I
had Ace and everyone's like what do you
mean he's just tapping you on the back
we gotcha
I see you you've said before like you
don't spend money on things personally
like you live in the studio I saw that
studio tour that was cool thank you that
was really cool and also really
inspiring too it's like two guys that
have a production company no it's cool
to see like what the possibilities are
thank you so that was really cool but
like you live there you live in
essentially like a little dorm room yeah
and like do you have a car I have a
Tesla because Tesla yeah electric [ __ ]
like that but even then I kind of want
to sell it I want to just have
everything I own fit in one picture so I
want to like basically pile all my stuff
on a bed and then just like that little
dorm room in my studio and then just
sell everything else you don't want
anything nice I think how do I put this
like I think one of the traps of like
modern humans is like just living a
materialistic life and just chasing [ __ ]
non-stop for what like why the [ __ ]
doesn't matter like we just Chase bigger
and bigger boxes to live in faster and
faster cars all this stuff but like why
why not just skip all that and just do
fun [ __ ] like make content or build a
business or things like that plus it
allows me to be more risky like if you
have a 10 million dollar mansion and
five Lamborghinis and all this [ __ ] then
you have to like worry like oh [ __ ] if
Things Fall Apart I can't afford my
lifestyle I don't give a [ __ ] I live in
a dorm room my [ __ ] could fall apart
tomorrow my lifestyle doesn't change
yeah there's also a lot of Peace of Mind
with that where I don't have to maintain
anything but you do enjoy some nice
things you fly private right not really
um because it's just it's expensive
right right
um you stayed in a Million Dollar Hotel
yeah like even if it's for the business
yeah exactly no I'm not denying that my
my life my life is great I love it uh I
just don't think like owning a mansion
is always cracked up to be our fast cars
but no obviously throughout the videos I
even being here I'm hanging out with you
guys and like I get to do cool [ __ ]
which is what I think is winning like
buying a mansion isn't winning like
finding a job you love and doing it over
the course of decades is winning you
know waking up every day happy to do
what you love that's true there is a
well-known phrase it goes as such Mo
Money Mo Problems
sorry that was a little meme all right
I'm gonna see you later man I think your
Uber's here let's go and head out
yeah yeah thanks for thanks for pulling
up today yeah that was good
um no but that's true though like the
bigger house you get the bigger the more
cars you get just comes with more
problems yep more chance that you could
be wiped out more mortgages more
liabilities Just For What who cares yeah
did you grow up in a way that made you
think that way or is that a conclusion
you kind of came to honestly I didn't
know growing up so I did have a little
phase where I bought like do you know
what an eye it is BMW yeah so I bought
one of those it's like 100 Grand is a
really nice car but just a giant waste
of time
um before I sold it I this is so it's
like a weird time I drop out of college
I grind I actually start making money
but I'm still living in like a [ __ ]
like 360 a month like a little duplex
house like so I'm living in this poor
house but I bought that my my car was
worth more than my house so like I
bought that car and then someone robbed
my house and then stole everything I
owned and it was like because the car
wasn't yeah because they're like oh this
car is worth more than that house let's
Rob the [ __ ] house so um and then I
got rid of the car and that was kind of
like that little phase but now I I know
like I I don't have to wake up and be
like oh would I be happier with the
Lamborghini like I know it didn't change
anything I think that's why I have such
an obsession with go-karts because it
like I it sometimes I wake up and I
think oh damn maybe one day I get like a
911 GT3 or something but then I just go
drive a go-kart that's like one percent
of the cost and I'm like oh it's the
same [ __ ] yeah it goes fast I guess I'll
buy the GT do it for a year and then I
think you'll realize it doesn't really
matter yeah no I mean
yeah
yeah no yeah definitely yeah
yeah
he has one yeah oh okay yeah
no I have a GT4 oh let's be clear let's
be clear it's even better uh no no it's
not no it's not and does it make you any
happier
um yes but in the sense that it's to me
it's kind of like the first and last you
know what I mean it's like I've dreamed
of like I don't want like the most
expensive sports car I just want like a
like a quintessential sports car and I
feel like that has achieved all I want
in a car and I've been in faster cars
and it doesn't it doesn't really make me
go oh [ __ ] I need this too I do think
the best things in life are free I had a
moment where I was like training for the
race I was like hiking and I was up on
the mountains just looking over this
beautiful view and I was like the best
this is the [ __ ] best yeah but I also
do really like to be like if I'm gonna
spend hours in my car every day in
traffic or whatever it's like I want the
to be comfortable okay yeah but you
don't have to spend a lot of money to
achieve that I think yeah you do
comfortable car I mean like luxury oh
sure I would prefer to be in luxury
that's fair you know yeah I mean there's
nothing wrong with it we're not judging
you at all
just that's that's cheaper than yours
hey that's just not for us yeah we're
better than that yeah that's fine yeah
yeah we're humble guys yeah yeah